we are on our way to orts adore in
central armenia a landscape that looks
barren at first but in which hundreds of
plants and animals live this man is
helping protect its biodiversity Reuben
khachatryan director of the foundation
for the preservation of wildlife and
cultural assets he's also a filmmaker in
his eco club khachatryan teaches young
people from the surrounding villages how
to love their home region by protecting
its natural assets their assignment
today is to photograph indigenous plants
two teams ten minutes and they're off
can the million speed kids like to play
and play they need toys we try to make
video and still cameras available to
them as toys so that they can connect
with nature Benden meet not wha yeah
this is pete seeger lesson these toys
help them get closer to nature did not
work on time's up the Leith Bazaar yawns
team gets back first lostock syllabic oh
I like the Eco Club I found out about
new plants and made new friends we're
protecting nature that sets us apart
from other teenagers quezada God's gnome
yes Sarge I want my green home to be
even greener I think about my health if
I protect nature i'm also protecting my
own health one mummies armenia has many
environmental problems that urgently
need solutions intensive farming
poaching illegal deforestation the young
people at the Sun child eco Club use
their short films to raise awareness
some of their films have won
international awards one of them is
silent scream
at first it shows our minion paradise
with animals and humans in harmony
then there's this a bear confined to a
cage to amuse its owner unfortunately
it's not unusual in Armenia thanks to
films like this the world at large can
learn about this small country in the
South Caucasus with its unique
biodiversity and many environmental
problems